coming up just down the road from us in
Carson California on Saturday night Fox
PBC fight night shawn porter against
your dennis Ogas coming up this coming
Saturday and then the following Saturday
on pay-per-view
Errol Spence vs. Mikey Garcia in the
Jones Mahal in Arlington Texas and here
to talk about that and so much more the
last heavyweight to hold the undisputed
heavyweight title none other than Lennox
Lewis good to see you sir thank you good
to see you so right off the bat I'd like
to have you correct somebody who's
working on that Garcia Spence yeah Mike
did you say you're working on the fight
yeah yeah what are you doing I'm mixing
the pregame before what for the fight
well before you said you said the game
before so you have to say match yes so
okay I'm sorry no it's okay Mike just
you know I mean it's the fellow boxing
I've never done boxing pre match the
pre-match coverage well I think what you
should take out of this Mike yes is that
in the four plus year history of this
show yes only one guest upon sitting
down in the seat in the commercial break
before coming on the air says you got to
correct Mike about something and it's
Lennox Lewis he went as far as like as
far off the flowchart as you possibly
can I actually did his audition when he
was are you wear this yeah no I worked
your audition at Fox that's right that's
right yeah do you do remember that yeah
I do
come on we know you that's the problem
yeah there you go
at least that's been confirmed by Lennox
Lewis good to see you here sir good to
see you what do you like about the
premier boxing champions and Fox Sports
getting together and doing this on
Saturday nights either on Fox fs1 or
pay-per-view this is let me tell you you
know I love about it is it's actually
bringing boxing back to the forefront
you know people kind of came off boxing
for a little bit
and it wasn't really exciting there
wasn't good
match-ups now you know Fox PBC they're
putting that together trying to give you
good fights good match matchups make
boxing exciting again bringing back
old-time fighters bringing back real
judges bringing back what do you mean by
real judges well judges that I've been
in the game for a long time and you know
when they when they say when they mark a
card you have to respect them because
that's who they are they've done it for
a long time so it's always interesting
to see the matchup where you get the Fox
judge against the judge that's at
ringside and and we try and compare them
the scoring sometimes it's way off and
sometimes it's correct so it's it's good
that the Fox has we have the real judge
the best judge right well it sounds like
you talking like a man who's had a draw
happened to him in his yes was back in
the day at least once or twice um so
what do we bring to the radio on it's as
well the arrow Spence against Mikey
Garcia coming up what do you like about
this match that's going down on
pay-per-view in a couple weekends from
now both undefeated both guys are great
fighters they've got a history of boxing
especially Mikey Garcia's coming from a
family of boxers Spence he's the young
young lightning guy he's the young guy
that's nobody's really heard about he's
making a fast move up to the top and
he's doing it fight by fire and each
fight you you always have to be
impressed with the way Ali disposes of
his opponent
I like that disposes of his opponent and
it's happening in the AT&T Stadium home
of the Dallas Cowboys yes who you used
to root for yes I did I used to love the
Dallas Cowboy Cheerleaders that's what
you like about the Dallas Cowboys well
you know they had that big thing with
the cheerleaders but definitely the team
mm-hmm so every have you met Jerry Jones
if you met tio one time one time in past
and I don't even think he remembers me
what do you mean
how'd he not remember letting meeting
Lennox Edwards happen in the world
that's right from back in the day well
you probably will see him there coming
up in a couple weeks usually goes to all
the big events that he's holding in his
own in his own house yeah you know I
said that about Tiger one time we you
know we're I we were watching a floyd
fight and tigers at ringside and i went
you know tiger what's up man and he kind
of looked at me and he's like who's that
guy and i was telling my friends like yo
dude tiger doesn't know who I am
come on man he must know who the
heavyweight champion of the world is
that he's had a fight I'm like he gave
me a funny look he said nah man don't
even listen to that so could I see that
you changed your hair Stone could that
be what I think that may have been part
of it you know I won the heavyweight
championship of the world and then I cut
my ear why'd you do that well I've got a
Samson like complex so as my hair grows
I get stronger yeah I don't know what
that feels Holyfield are you tight with
him anyway [ __ ] yeah how often you chat
with him whenever we get together I was
accusing of head-butting me
he's always arguing that he didn't right
and you know I bring the argument to the
forefront tell the people don't you
think he head-butted me in the fight and
then we started a little discussion
argument and then we talked about
something else
yeah his son was just at the NFL
Scouting Combine made me feel really old
he plays football at Georgia and he's
getting ready to go in the NFL Wow I
know right
athletic family it's pretty amazing how
these things go along now let me get in
a couple things here that I've always
wanted to ask you
Tyson bit you for real at the press
conference yeah hey Jimmy boom you're
getting set to fight Mike Tyson right
and then what happened well you know
we're having a press conference and you
know they announced me or my accolades
announce him then all of a sudden he
came walking over to me he threw his hat
down on the ground I looked at it as a
declaration of war and he walked over he
walked over to me and my security
stopped and he took a swipe at my
security and then the battle began and
everybody started jumping in at the
bottom of the pile was me and him
and they were clearing everybody off and
I would say haze biting my leg and
they'd say everybody's like you know
that shock look what am i security
seeing him and they start giving him
some elbows and he released smile egg so
and that's that's how it happened he bit
your leg yeah you don't still have a
scar for me absolutely
dude I would drop my pants buddies we're
on TV it's that high up are you serious
right here on your thigh on my thigh so
it still exists to this very day yes it
doesn't how many people can say they
have a scar from Mike Tyson Evander I
mean that we kind of know of yeah I just
remember that was one of the most
incredible pay-per-view events
I remember that covering that in ESPN
and then I remember when you started
throwing down on ESPN write it up close
that was a theme rock rock man yeah
Walkman I mean I went to this press
conference remember that's Chris watch I
just found the video right now obviously
in the suit brand new shoes you know I
didn't go there to fight so I wasn't
prepared to fight so where are your
shoes now I say now the reason I say
that is because I was slipping sliding
all over the place and Rahman took me
down pretty easy well as I was going
down I grabbed his chain so I had this
chain and you know there was a big
battle a battle of like yeah come get it
idea to come get it and obviously it's
his chain he wants to come get it so but
you know the people split us apart mmm
so ten minutes after that I gave him his
chain back I didn't want to take his
chain you know but you won the rematch
though so oh yeah he got that one down
I remember Gary Miller meat was hosting
it and we were all like oh my god what
the heck was just okay that was
unbelievable I know my friends were
there and they were like they were
shocked too like they were trying to get
over to help me so you know it's one of
those unexpected things that happen in
boxing that we we sorted out in the end
but you know you see stuff sometimes
certainly with the UFC these days where
obviously all holy heck broke loose just
a couple of months ago with Conor
McGregor and and the immediate reaction
was that's good in the fact like
obviously the people who were involved
the liability was don't think it's good
but it eventually that means more people
are gonna be watching and interested or
do you agree subscribe to that notion it
I described when it's real I like real
stuff I don't like stuff that's put on
oh let's just push each other and make
it and make a big deal out of it if it's
real it's real and then there's
situations where I've seen fighters get
together and they pick up a glass and
throw out the other person like what are
you doing
you know you gotta listen to Don King oh
that's what he said to me so I listen by
the way I never thought I would hear
Lennox Lewis say you gotta listen to Don
King I never say some white wise things
on occasion on occasions is he still not
your favorite person right you know okay
he's gotten by there's a lot lot to
learn from him and lot not to learn from
him so like everybody else you meet Ali
URI Dali
yeah first time I met Ali was like Pan
American Games at one time he was
watching me fight for the first time you
know how that feels
you got Muhammad Ali out there watching
you fight you knew he was out there yeah
everybody you know the big whisper he's
out days out there all right I'm boxing
I want to impress him what can I do so I
worked as hard as I can and you know the
refs didn't see it or the referee or the
judges never seen it my way but still
got out of the ring went to meet him and
he said hey you pretty good I'll see you
down the line so that was half I was
happy you know I did lose but the same
guy I lost to I'd beat two weeks later
and beat him so it was like I would have
wanted to win to impress Muhammad Ali
and show him how good I am but I didn't
get that chance hmm but you had a
conversation with him I had a
conversation with him at that time he
was just creeping into the Parkinson's
situation and
you know other times after that last I
met him I went to his birthdays and you
know his events that he's had so hmm
what do you think of the current state
of the heavyweight division Lennox Lewis
current state of the heavyweights you
know it's funny because I did things my
way when I was heavyweight champion and
or even trying to be heavyweight
champion and my main thing was you know
I wanted to be the undisputed champion
obviously these heavyweights nowadays
have goals of being undisputed in the
only one but they're not in a rush for
it you know you know the main guy
Anthony Joshua it's interesting he says
oh you know our box the ante next year
or the year after I'm like dude if that
wasn't me I need to box you now I need
to be the champion now but this is their
error they can do things they the way
they want to do it I know what I would
do in my era which is fight the guy the
first second you possibly yeah yeah who
knows if you get that chance again this
is what happen this is what's happened
to him now now he's being put on the
Shelf he has to box a guy that nobody
really wants to see him box
you know big baby Miller he's doing a
great job hyping up the fight but in
England nobody really knows him then
when you look back at his fights
he's only been 12 rounds one time so as
far as him making it wait his way
through the fight I don't know if he's
gonna make it all the way through the
fight doesn't make for a good fight then
you got Tyson Fury
he's just signing with ESPN you got
Deonte which is doing something else so
they're all kind of split apart doing
their own things so when you look at the
undisputed champion you know who's gonna
be nobody can really tell right now
because each one of them are gonna have
a fight and each one of them we're gonna
take a chance every time they fight do
you think Fury should have been counted
out I think the ref made an awesome
decision to do that because I've seen in
some actually I've been in fights where
you know I'm the heavyweight champion of
the world
man's knocked me down in the second
round I've gotten up and the referees
going call him the fight I'm going it's
the second round come on it's not like
he was beating me up for 12
but this happens in boxing so when the
referee decided to do that I was like
that was a brave move but it worked out
in the end
I met Wilder recently he is I mean
absolutely mammoth just a big dude I
would not want to be on the business end
of that who is the best fighter in the
heavyweight division right now in your
estimation Lennox Louis I think that
it's between three guys okay they're all
over six five and the guys that I just
mentioned you know I'm really big on
tight Tyson Fury because you know this
is a man that's gone through mental
situations where you know he's been
through weight situations where you know
he gained a whole bunch of pounds and
still after a layoff he's come back and
basically matched up to the number one
and second guy out there so and he took
that chance he answered the call for
England he said I'm coming over to
America and I'm boxing beyond today I'm
like you know this is a fighter this is
a man this is this is the kind of mind
that you want to have being a champion
Bret taking on all challenges you know
it's amazing you mentioned the size of
those three guys do you think we'll ever
see somebody Tyson size 5-11 gonna
dominate that division ever again no I
don't think so it may there may be
another Tyson around butter but I don't
know 511 511 but you know Tyson had a
big neck he couldn't you couldn't knock
him out easy and a big you know set of
teeth from what you're telling yes we
had we had Mike on we had Mike on what's
two years ago or something like that
yeah and it was a time when we had a
commercial break in the middle of our
show just for a minute in between so if
you were on a few years ago I would have
said hey well beats that stop right here
we'll be back in 60 seconds and I asked
Mike towards the end of the you know
about nine minutes in how many rounds
can you give me right now and he goes I
don't want to think about it cuz if I
ever think about boxing I go to a bad
place and I'm like okay well we will be
right back
you seem to be met it may be in a better
mindset oh yeah how many rounds how many
rounds can you give me right now Lennox
Lewis oh I couldn't give you a lot of
rounds just don't ring a bell around me
what do you mean like ding ding my hands
go up just like that sort of reaction
well you know that's a boxer's reaction
ding ding it's ready to go to ready time
to go to work but how many rounds I mean
like ding ding how many rounds could
there we go there it is
see you tell Eve now that you know it's
a match look at you you know you're
trying to impress Lennox Lewis how many
rounds could you give me you think
you're talking with you know just the
human race if if you can get back in the
ring how many rounds do you think you
could go and at least at least ten not
fantastic yeah any any thoughts of doing
something like that you know people
always talk about oh they want to see me
and Mike Tyson again I'm like I don't
think Mike Tyson wants to see me in them
again so you know it'll be interesting
because I always thought about you know
why don't these you know over 40's fight
all over 50 cc senior tours right yeah I
don't think it'll work in boxing you
know I don't know you're during your
early 50s you'll find someone match you
up with oh I got a do it like Floyd go
over there and pretend to fight somebody
I love that all right before I let you
go Lennox your favorite cereal it's
national cereal day do you want cereal
yes favorite sir I can't believe nobody
said raisin brand I love raisins
nobody says raisin bran embrace it the
brazen bran is just a brandy you're a
little backed up and you need to that's
when you have raisins I love raisins I
love the sweet raisins you just add milk
no sugar
the raisins is the sugar okay so you
just do it yourself see and also
shredded wheats come on come on
what kind of cereal you guys eat great
to see you Lennox Lewis yeah Lennox
Lewis on Twitter at mr. Lennox Lewis on
Instagram Porter Lucas
on Fox at 8 Eastern this very Saturday
from right here in Carson and then the
first ever Fox Sports pay-per-view event
with premier boxing champions the IBF
welterweight champion arrow Spence and
the WBC lightweight champion Mikey
Garcia from AT&T Stadium in a couple of
Saturdays check it all out thanks for
coming on my thanks you got it the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience